to CBS this morning the mayor of
Lexington Kentucky is moving quickly to
relocate to Confederate monuments from
outside a historic former courthouse
Mayor Jim Gray said the weekend's deadly
violence in Charlottesville led him to
announce his plans Saturday Lexington is
one of many cities like Charlottesville
debating the meaning of these
Confederate symbols Michelle Miller is
in Lexington and looks at the strong
emotions they generate Michelle good
morning good morning this is a statue of
John C Breckinridge a former US vice
president and the last Confederate
Secretary of War now the mayor wants to
remove this statue and another like it
relocated to a nearby park honoring
veterans
he knows it's a move it could spark
another fiery public debate over what
these monuments represent the violent
clash in Charlottesville Virginia is the
latest in a series of tense
demonstrations over plans to remove
Confederate monuments to San Antonio
communities across the south are taking
a critical look at these symbols and in
some cases or removing them Lexington
Kentucky mayor jim gray wire mayor's
across the country bringing these
statues town now mayors are on the
razor's edge when you see the tension
when you see the violence that we saw in
Charlottesville then you know that we
must act the lexington monuments were
built near the historic site of one of
the country's the largest slave auction
blocks I don't think it's right that we
would honor and glorify Confederate men
who fought to preserve slavery and honor
them on the very grounds that slaves
were once sold at auction but he's
likely to face strong opposition after
the city of Charlottesville approved the
removal of the statue of Robert Ely
earlier this year it was targeted by the
Ku Klux Klan and white nationalist in
New Orleans
city leaders faced two years of court
battles and a handful of violent
protests over their plan to remove for
Confederate landmarks
the Southern Poverty Law Center has
found 1,500 symbols or places that pay
homage to Confederate leaders and says
there have been at least 100 state and
local attempts to remove the monuments
or provide more historical context the
some who want the monuments to stay say
we're moving them is erasing an
important part of the country's past and
see them as the landmarks throughout the
south oh my god I'll just leave them
alone and leave more they are you know
they're part of history when we place
those along the Veterans War memorial
walk then that story can be told to
young people hiding that story erasing
that story that doesn't teach us but
telling the story does keep in mind that
Kentucky citizens fought on both sides
of the Civil War which is why the mayor
wants Breckinridge statue to stand
nearby his Union counterparts and this
is not a done deal yet the mayor needs
the approval of the City Council and the
Kentucky military heritage Commission
Jeff Michelle Miller thank you